hi there Steve Kaufman here today to
talk about today I'm going to talk about
repetition and novelty and if you enjoy
my videos on language learning please
subscribe by the way I am closing in on
100,000 subscribers so I don't know what
I'll do and I hit that number maybe I'll
go out with my wife and or will open a
bottle of champagne at home but it's
been fun over the past 10 years I've
really really enjoyed doing this because
it's part of what I'm interested in
which is learning languages over the
past 10 years while I've been making
these videos I think I've learned seven
or eight languages and now I'm on to
Greek as you know so it's very much part
of what I'm doing and what I enjoy doing
and I like sharing my experience with
others and my experience does also
include a reading on how languages are
required so repetition um obviously
repetition is good you need to see words
many times before they stick you need to
see certain patterns in the language
many times before they start to become
part of you know what you're comfortable
doing but as I have pointed out before
when I mentioned the work of Robert
Bjork who talks about interleaving we
can't just focus on sort of a limited
amount of data and just try to master it
because you read it over and over again
hoping that it's going to stick in our
brain it won't it's it's you're going
over the same ground all the time and
every time you go over the same ground
you're picking up less and less so it's
very important to vary that with novelty
I often quote Manfred Spitzer the famous
German neuroscientist who said to learn
the brain needs repetition and novelty
you have to feed the brain something new
you know and I'm assuming people are
curious anyone who isn't curious for
know--they isn't going to learn anyone
who thinks they can simply by rote
memory and by not being curious about
the language how the line with language
works
curious about things in the culture that
person simply isn't going to learn so
our very well so so plain repetition
rote memory although there are people
who swear by it I'm going to memorize
the most important thousand words are
going to memorize that grammar ace the
grammar I have never found that that
works
and I noticed that recently because with
my Greek I've been doing our mini
stories and I've not got up to 40 mini
stories that we have loaded up at linked
audio and text and but because our
writer who's writing these stories has
now slowed down we don't have any new
stories and therefore they have been
translated and so I am going over the
same stories over and over and over
again because the same newspaper
articles that I can find on the Internet
are still too difficult for me for Greek
so I stay with these stories but I'm
realizing that I'm getting less and less
out of them and that when I go and do a
newspaper article or something more
difficult and I come back to the stories
again the simple stories I get a little
more again because I varied it a bit so
it's very important to introduce that
novelty and it does not just apply to
that and and also not only novelty but
that sense that you're moving forward
that you're achieving so if I read
something on link where there are a lot
of blue words and I'm converting them to
yellow I'm looking them up then I have
the sense that I'm achieving something
right if I'm going over the same stuff
over and over and over again hoping that
it's kind of gradually you know cause my
neuron neurons to fire together but
after a while I think there's just no
novelty there and so the return on
investment is less and less and this
applies to many things it applies to
grammar get 3 grammar resources read
them bolt read them all and cover the
same ground from three different angles
before we had link I used to buy three
starter books teacher self colloquial
level living language cover the same
ground from three different angles or
borrow them from the library in other
words the greater the variety that you
can introduce to your repetition the
more fresh then that repetition is going
to be and I even find that when I go say
in my Greek and I do something very
difficult I'm struggling yourself when I
go back then to my Greek stories I'm
picking up more and another thing that
I've done talking again about variety
and repetition because the Greek stories
the original
mornings of them were very fast and in
some ways it was good because it made me
you know more comfortable with someone
speaking quickly but then I thought
maybe some of our learners would be
discouraged by having the audio so fast
so I asked Pablo Saar a Greek translator
and fellow who's doing the recordings to
do them again more slowly and now I
listen to them again slowly and I'm
picking up a lot more so just varying
the speeds is another form of
introducing novelty variety so I think
that's extremely important not to rely
on rote memory or any you know
expectation that by really focusing and
learning and and repeating that somehow
things are going to stick you have to
follow Manfred Spitzer's advice you have
to mix up the repetition with the
novelty so there you have it thank you
for listening bye for now
[Music]
you
[Music]